I'm just lost. I got a really
emotional and important message from One of my YouTube viewers
Love you guys John and I wanted to read it and then answer it and I got a lot of comments with this one
Really moved me and is is is really important. It's really important for you guys to
Understand this because I know a lot of you are going through it [let] me read. It. Here's a dilemma for you, Eric
Okay, we know it's Evan right. It's not Eric. I don't know I think I have an entrepreneurial atd.
I started a few years ago thinking that I wanted to start a shop to work on cars bikes and so on I've been
tinkering on cars from the age of 12 I'm 22 now.
I went out and got a job in industry really enjoyed it ended up starting my own shop about five months ago and [now] [I]
Couldn't be more bored of it.
I still enjoyed working on cars, and it's always going to be a hobby of mine, but every day is becoming tedious and annoying
So I ended up quitting the business. I working for a company doing the exact same thing
Which is actually more fun that way for me because I enjoy being around people and the shopper
Hat was literally just me and I had my girlfriend coming after her job and helped do silly things but even now
I'm not truly satisfied
I like the feeling of owning my own business and knowing that it's all under my control of my own hands
I really don't know why I feel that way.
but it's just the way it is I think I'm going to start heading in the direction of being around people
Maybe buying and selling items may be some sort of retail business
I might start buying and selling instruments for I've played music also for my whole life
I guess what I'm wrapping it all up.
To question you is what do you think I should do I feel like I'm never going to find the right direction.
I'm really hoping that all this pans out, and I enjoy the next path.
I tempted to go down, but everybody is telling me hey stick with something and it's actually starting to make me worry
I do have to settle down some point my life.
I have bills and an apartment.
But I really enjoyed cars really enjoy music really enjoy buying and selling things.
Retail wise. I enjoy being on people and enjoyed festivals and festivities.
I'm just lost in the sauce on what path to go down any advice.
so it's a long message john as you know at his wits and ease all out there for you and
You know I really feel for John and and this is such an important topic, okay?
This is such an
important topic because most people they get up and they drive to a job that they hate and
They're living for the evenings and weekends right that's eighty percent of America plus. They wake up
They're driving to this company that they can't stand and then they're just they can't wait for quitting time
And they're waiting for what they're gonna do on the weekends. That's when they live and and for me
That's not a way to live. I don't want to just live for my weekends in my evenings
I want to be doing meaningful important work
If that's running my own business or if it's taking a job if that's what I meant to do
But I want to be doing something where I feel like I'm having an impact what I'm doing is important
So the path that you need to follow is this there's three simple steps one explorer?
To follow the flow and three pivot, okay?
What does that mean let me break it down one explorer you got to explore things, [okay]? You got to try stuff
You don't know if you're going to like something until you actually go in and do it
You don't look at Data and say well arm this type of person
so I'm going to go into this type of job go and try and see if it works if you like it right and
Congratulations first of all.
For having the guts to go out and launch your own shop and say you know what I want to explore this I'm going to
Go and do it and so it didn't work and so you're gonna
Go do something else, but you have to keep exploring and don't listen to your friends and family who say hey
It's time to settle down
Now it's time for you to join the rest of the world and live a crappy life, right?
Is that what you want to do? So so it didn't work out once you took one shot, and that's it
You give up, and you live the life everybody else hates that's not the answer you got to get up and try again
explore and small starts
Start something on a small level and just try it out
Stop thinking about something and get out of your head and start actually
Doing something and see if you enjoy it you might try something and you hate it and now you know you have your answer
You may try something and you love it, and you want to do more and more and more you get obsessed with it
That's number two. You follow your flow
You see what you love doing. You're trying a bunch of stuff right at this point
You don't know what to do go and try stuff?
You're going to keep doing the stuff that you love to do. There's some things you're going to try take wow
This is awesome, and you want to keep doing it and keep doing it center
The whole day is passed by like what happened to my day. It was amazing. [you] [want] to do it again?
You're obsessed with you. Think about it when you're sleeping
Maybe you wake up early the next day because you can't wait to go and do it again, right?
So you're following your flow if you get in that zone you got to stay there? That's where the great stuff happens
When you're following your flow not doing some crappy job that you don't like anymore if it's tedious and boring
Don't do it you think you're going to build a great life doing stuff. That's tedious and boring
No, you got to do the stuff that makes you come alive, so you have to follow your flow you explore
You follow the flow number three is pivot you might find that after following your flow
It doesn't work out anymore the passion goes away, right? You started your car thing you thought hey. This is great
This is what I always wanted to do you tried five months later
It's not working out you pivot you go do something else. You start exploring again
That's okay sometimes that flow lasts for a month six months a year a decade
You know you don't know how long it's Gonna last
I'm making these videos okay, let me tell you two stories. I'm making these videos, okay?
I got a whole bunch of stuff in my career a
New idea comes along I love to try it just to explore. I explore a whole bunch of stuff most of it doesn't work out
Sometimes I try something and and I like it for a little bit
And I continue on doing it and then I get bored of it
So I either close it down or if it's important to the company. I give it to somebody else too many choose
I don't want to touch it because if I was
continuing to do that my business wouldn't grow because me doing stuff that I hate or
Board up or tedious or don't like anymore?
That's not going to be me building a great company, so I'm making these videos. I love making these videos
It's one of the favorite parts of my week
It's answering your questions seeing what comes in and feeling like hey
I'm helping people out your comments coming back is fuel for me every single day
Maybe one day. I'll get bored of it
if I don't like video day, if I if it's Wednesday when I record all these videos and uh
Man, I got to do more videos this sucks man hate this
You think I'm going to make great videos with that attitude?
no, so I would have to shut it down and
That would be very sad.
At least right now. I love the video so I'm going to keep going for now, but you will have that moment
Where you make it tight or something, and it's okay to move on okay?
Let me tell you one more quick story that I've told the forints of my videos this applies, not just a business
But what you do in your life, and I remember I've tried three activities recently
Okay
dancing
Rock climbing and
Snowboarding the rock climbing one I went rock climbing somebody invited me so hey sure I've never done rock climbing let me try that I
Hated it okay. I hate rock climbing had a terrible experience
You know I'm afraid of heights at all like looking [down]. I don't like feeling like I can't reach the next thing the strap was
Anyway, whatever. [I] didn't like it. I'm not going to go back again. That's cool. I'm okay with it
I'm okay with having tried it not having this I wish I could do things I [don't] have this I wish I could do list
If I want to do something I go out and try it so rock climbing is not for me then I tried snowboarding
Somebody said hey join us for a snowboarding trip. I've never gone snowboarding. Hey, why [not] let's try it out and
I loved it and and I became obsessed with it the next week. I went [on] bought all my gear
I bought my own board the boots the hat the coat everything
I wanted and bought everything. I need to be snowboarding, and I would I would spend
Every day in the winter snowboarding every single day. I went snowboarding because I loved it so much
I would be like waiting for meetings to end so I can go
Snowboarding it might even rush through video day like guys can I got an hour?
I can go hit the snowboarding hill. There's one close to where I live
I loved it and that lasted for two years and then in my interests has started to fade
It's always gonna be part of me. I think I love snowboarding. It's still great, but I'm not obsessed. I don't wake up
You know in the more like oh, I can't wait to go snowboarding, right?
I'll, I'll push a meeting so I can go snowboarding right, so the the passion is faded the third one is salsa
and dancing Salsa
You look at it on paper, and it it's it was a stupid decision for me to get into Salsa, right?
I'm too tall I took huge steps. I have no dance background. I didn't understand the music. I don't speak the language
I don't know any of the moves
I'm starting so late in life like this is never going to be something that would would on paper
Look good for me to do right, so this is um if I went in thinking
This is my next business opportunity is my next love that
I'm going to fall in love with [alright] the next thing that's going to skyrocket me
It would make any I'm probably even trying because it didn't make any sense logically
but I went I went to the first class and I just loved it and
I would go back and do more. I couldn't get enough sauce
I'm listening to the music and I'm watching the videos and learning [turn] patterns the guy's
Responsibility is to lead what I call turn patents
You're leading the moves
And I remember thinking that night about moves that I can come up with and I remember being in meetings with with
Guys for business, and I would imagine if I took his hand and moved his arm like this
oh, I could make this new turn pattern and I'd like to zoom out of my meeting and then come back
Because I was thinking about Salsa, and it became this passion. It's been going 10 years now, and I'm an investor in
the largest Salsa dance studio in Canada Maybe North America teach five six thousand students a year how to dance salsa
It's a huge part of my life. I'll
DJ. And then teach some of the classes and it's it's been awesome
And so I'm following the flow right I explored
I followed the flow and I haven't pivoted off a salsa like I did off of snowboarding because I still love it
And it's worked out for me, and I would have never thought about getting into that so when you're first getting started, right?
We're in this stage now
You don't know what to do you feel this pressure that you need to
Settle down you need to figure out what you're going to do with your life, and it's all Chaos
And you don't know what to do and when you force yourself into a decision
It's not going to be a great one right you force yourself to go get a job
You're not going to be great or happy in that life right whenever you've got a gun to your head to make a decision
Right now that's never the best one you need to give yourself the space
to explore
the follow your flow and to pivot and
Remember that all these people who are trying to force you to make a decision. They hate their lives, too
They're not doing anything great
So why are you taking advice from people who haven't done great things in their life? You look at the people?
who've done great things and a lot of them have bounced from something to something [to] something and explore it and fail and failed and
Tried something it didn't work out
Before they hit their thing that helps them explode
Research famous entrepreneurs look at the people who you look up to and respect and learn from their success
This is where it comes from if you want to be great
You want to help have a huge impact on the world you want to live a fulfilled life?
Then you have to remember explore follow your flow and pivot believe
Those are watching and like the video support me by clicking on the link in the description leave a comment
let me know what you think and
Click on my face scar to the channel if you want to see more videos like this. Thank you so much. I'll see you soon